I have a question I mean was there a
moment with porn where you like kind of
picked your head up and you're like I'm
[__] jerking off to the Family Guy ad
it's like was there a defining moment
where you're like oh this has gone too
deep I noticed that
um in relationships if I was acting out
with porn that like you know I just
wasn't getting it done yeah it's with my
lady you know like it's it's like taking
your energy
it's taking your energy away from the
relationship and put that into a sock
yeah yeah I was just wondering because
you know with a lot of uh addiction
stuff it's like you kind of have a
moment where you wake up and you go last
night was too much or you have a a
moment where you're like I gotta get my
[__] together I always wondered was it a
video but it sounds like yours was just
kind of an experience well I mean for me
man oh yeah they think I'm fine I want
to go there the whole like sex addiction
thing yeah
um man I uh
there there was this this
chick that I met after uh one of my
shows a long time ago this was uh yeah
beginning of 2013. and she was with a
dude
and I'm like oh yeah she she was like
stoked to meet me and I'm like oh like
let me get your numbers and went right
in front of her dude oh wow she gives me
the gives gives me your number and then
and then like I hit her up after and
she's like oh you know I'm with this
dude and I was like okay no fair enough
fair enough but then like like a week or
two later she's like I broke up with the
dude I'm like right on cool so I fly her
out yeah to uh to LA and and you know
we're doing our thing
I remember too I used to be pretty good
about like uh protection stuff in this
case like we just we weren't yeah yeah
we're just we're just rocking it
rawing it raw dogging it up and uh and
so we've been we've been at that for a
couple days and then I'd take her up on
this hike to go get a photo with the
Hollywood Sign there you go she says you
know it's so weird you know that guy I
was with his last relationship before me
was with a dude
and I'm like oh oh I see where you're
going now I'm thinking like this is high
risk for for your boy yeah high risk for
like for HIV you know and I'm like
spinning I'm spinning I remember like we
got back to my apartment and and I'm
like I gotta walk the dogs and while I'm
walking the dogs around the block I'm
just Googling statistics on oh yeah well
also Hollywood has so many of those
Billboards it's like one in three HIV
you have two dogs you're like it's
[__] not me
I'm uh yes I'm freaking out but then I
get back to the pad and I'm like well
you know like
I'm already in it this far but it was
true
and so here here um you know and then
I'm just doing it again and while I'm
doing it again I'm thinking like man
what is my deal yeah you know that was
like
how long did you get into something
after that like a program
um
I that was when I first reached out to
someone saying hey you know I need
and I need to get it get a handle on
this and and and
trying to get a handle on it
that I just couldn't yeah like I started
seeing a sex therapist and they said uh
you know like it's gonna be important
for you to to to be like celibate for
like a period you know let's try
I think he said like let's try two weeks
we're just now we're not gonna do
anything you know like no no no nothing
no nothing I think it's weird how
celibacy doesn't really get uh
celebrated you know like if if your
friends like I'm six months off alcohol
you're like that's [__] great but
like I feel like winning friends like I
haven't had sex in six months you're
like [__] [__] you know like you
feel like right it's like I'm not yeah I
remember telling that like I was trying
it and I didn't just couldn't I could I
couldn't you know yeah and I it was this
comedy of errors and at the time I was
doing stand-up and like I was just
getting I was just like getting material
out of like how how impossible it was
for me to to yeah and and it turned out
that like that whole first hour my whole
first special was like you know very
focused on on issues with sex
um but I remember like I got to a point
where I really was you know it's
committed to I ended up going to this
this outpatient sex addict rehab
and uh and and coming out of there
that's how I met Scott I was like yo I
just got out of sex addict rehab you
guys are the same place
um no I didn't go but it's kind of the
same rooms okay yeah so so I'm like I
just got out of sex addict rehab and I
got to go back on tour I have no chance
whatsoever that's the ultimate final
test I need a c blocker yeah yeah your
therapist is like now you're gonna do a
50 City tour in all the U.S near college
towns right so so I was like if I was
like maybe you know if you come on the
road like uh you can sell merch at my
shows for me and like you can get some
money like uh coming in from that
special paid [__] block that's great
yeah and and that was exactly how it
started and then so that was how Scott
started with my merch operation but
that's beautiful so I was I was celibate
for over a year and I remember telling
Knox I was like dude I didn't even blow
a load [__] it's been like six months
Knoxville's like dude he's really
concerned he says to me um he says dude
that's like uh that's how you're gonna
get uh testicular cancer if you let it
back up damn and I remember Santa
Knoxville like dude I'm pretty sure that
if uh
if if jacking off was the cure for
testicular cancer nobody would have it
could you imagine that the doctor's like
I got good news and bad news and he just
slides Brazzers across the table I can
save you yeah
that's wild I mean that's that's like a
rumor that like a 17 year old would
start like if you don't jack off dude
you're gonna lose a ball
there's a yellow five would you ever
hear that yellow five yeah Mountain Dew
make your balls smaller oh I did hear
that yeah and there was a period where I
would have a bag of Skittles and I would
put the yellows to the side I'd be like
[__] not today okay
I need these all right or like uh if you
have acnes because you have too much
sperm built up inside you I've never
heard that I've never heard that really
it's just trying to get out of your box
has the white heads on it you know I
didn't even tell you that if anything it
would be the other way around can you
imagine if that was like oh you're like
you're getting acne because you have a
like two depleted uh you know too much
that would be wild
rocking a hard spot yeah that's how
Kellogg started was to like lower the
sex drive the cereal the cereal I think
it was meant to lower the the sex drive
Kellogg cereal well I mean saying the
word Kellogg is probably the least horny
thing you can do besides Raisin Bran so
yeah like back in the day that's maybe I
I don't maybe it was a [__] Tick Tock
I saw yeah something I read but I
remember the opposite Wheaties is like
eat this you'll be an athlete you'll
probably have sex yeah you'll shoot
ropes whoa yeah
[Music]
exactly dude e-commerce is the way and
that way ladies and gentlemen is called
ship station now to enjoy a 60-day free
trial you go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo again that is 60 days two months
of hassle-free stress-free shipping with
ship station
yeah dude